I told you that all the magical breath
attacks that you see in How to Train
Your Dragon are real ice breath fire
breath lightning acid sound all of them
are just waiting for you to unlock in
fact most of them aren't even that hard
to achieve just get ready for a little
dose of science on the way what can I
say we're theorists it's an occupational
hazard
internet welcome to
show that's been dragged on you to learn
things since 2015. you know when it
comes fantasy creatures nothing is quite
as iconic as the dragon and right now
they seem to be undergoing a bit of a
Renaissance in Pop Culture House of the
Dragon basically saved the Game of
Thrones IP there are Whispers of a new
Spyro game in the works there's the new
Dungeons and Dragons movie with a TV
show not far behind and the DND live
stream critical role has had two seasons
of their show adapted into the genuinely
fantastic Legend of Vox Machina even
Universal is starting to get in on the
trend announcing that they're gonna go
the Disney route by giving How to Train
Your Dragon a live action remake and
that's in addition to the 19 seasons of
Television that they've already made out
of this thing so with all this Dragon
talk going on I decided to re-binge the
entire How to Train Your Dragon series
and of course my theorist brain started
to do the thing that all theorist brains
do it started over analyzing everything
about the film specifically I was
fascinated by all the different breath
attacks that the dragons in the world
seem to have sure you've got yourself
your classic fire breath but over the
course of the series we also learn about
dragons who use boiling water
electricity ice acid even sound the
creatures that use all these attacks are
also really diverse in terms of their
size and appearance which got me
wondering is any of this actually
possible what would animals who use
these sorts of attacks actually look
like How to Train Your Dragon puts a
surprising amount of care into their
dragon designs but do they actually hold
up to real world scrutiny well Saddle Up
loyal theorists today we're looking at
the biology of these dragons to see
which of the breath attacks are the most
biologically sound let me tell you if
dragons like the ones that we see here
existed in the real world most effective
power isn't the one that you'd expect so
I think we should just go ahead and get
the granddaddy of all dragon breath
attacks out of the way first here the
iconic fire breath now obviously no
lizard or reptile in nature actually
straight up breathes fire like a dragon
that's an entirely fictional thing for
men but believe it or not this sort of
thing is very feasible in nature and we
can say say this thanks to an itty bitty
little insect called the bombardier
beetle now we've already talked about
this in detail in an episode about the
terrifying truth of fire Pokemon over on
our sister location Game Theory so just
to quickly sum this one up when
threatened the bombardier beetle shoots
out scolding chemicals at its foes it
does this by using three organs in its
abdomen two of those organs are glands
that produce hydroquinones and hydrogen
peroxide the third organ is where those
two chemicals mix together when combined
they perform a reduction oxidation
reaction which basically means that they
get themselves really really hot the
Bombardier beetle then shoots that
liquid at whatever threat they perceive
now what the bombardier beetle shoots is
a heated liquid which lines up well with
the skulldrons that we hear about and
how to train your dragon skaldrin sprays
scalding water and its victim extremely
dangerous but what about more actual
fire well this same concept could work
with a variety of different chemical
combinations for instance potassium
chlorate and ordinary table sugar when
combined with a drop of sulfuric acid
releases large quantities of heat energy
in the form of awesome purple Flames
like legitimately a purple flame viewing
Dragon would be awesome on the less
awesome but still very biologically
feasible side are farts you see in a
short we released earlier this week we
took a closer look at the new Dungeons
and Dragons movie to see just how its
Dragon uses fire breath based on the
footage that we see in the film you can
see that it breathes out a clear gas
that then ignites using a spark in the
back of its throat or just general heat
in the world around it that gas that
it's spewing that's likely methane a gas
that occurs naturally in almost all
animals in the form of farts it's clear
it's flammable and well it would bring
new meaning to the phrase dragon breath
I guess the old saying is true why fart
and waste it we can burp and light it on
fire to Scorch your foes to death so now
that we've figured out a few mechanisms
for fire breath time to get creative
what about some of the more unusual
types of breath attacks that we see in
these movies like say electric breath
it's something that we see in fantasy
media all the time the legend of Vox
Machina begins with a giant blue dragon
and nothing is more iconic than
Yu-Gi-Oh's blue eyes white dragon and
its White Lightning attack go White
Lightning attack
[Applause]
except both of these examples result in
one major problem electricity is
unpredictable electric charges are
created when electrons jump between
objects since electrons are negatively
charged particles having fewer electrons
creates a positive electric charge and
having a bunch of extra electrons
creates a negative charge and when the
difference between the positive and the
negative get big enough the electrons
jump to balance themselves out to become
neutral again the problem is it'll do
this with literally anything it can find
the electricity doesn't care it'll just
go to the closest thing that it can
trade electrons with but for an electric
breath attack to work the dragons
wouldn't just need to change its
electron count it would also need a way
to make sure that its Target was the
best option to transfer electrons with
and the only way to do that would be by
manipulating the amount of electrons the
target has that said directing lightning
can be done back in January of 2012
reports started to circulate about the
US Army testing a lightning weapon one
that was able to attack using 50 billion
watts of energy how they manage to
control the lightning using a laser it
was called the laser-induced plasma
Channel or lipc for sure short basically
how it worked was that a laser would put
out a pulse of energy this pulse had to
be incredibly brief only about two
trillionths of a second but that was
enough to create a path for the
lightning to follow before that in 1993
the U.S Air Force and Naval weapons
research divisions both successfully
conducted tests into plasma railguns
devices intended to capture plasma and
then launch it in specific directions
basically they were trying to weaponize
balls of lightning that were hotter than
the surface of the Sun and could
detonate with an explosive force of five
pounds of TNT on contact all while
discharging an electromagnetic burst
that could scramble most electronic
devices in the area and while that was
certainly impressive what was even more
impressive was this thing's name project
Marauder with Marauder actually being a
real acronym that stood for real words
that made sense get this magnetically
accelerated ring to achieve ultra high
directed energy and radiation slow clap
I hope that someone got a raise for
coming up with that one and while both
projects did wind up being successful
the only problem were the power demands
they were too high for weapons that had
such limited range which made him
impractical and the projects went away
in short the best way of making a
lightning weapon work for both the
military and by extension our Dragon
Friends is to get really darn close to
the intended target which then
encourages the lightning to jump over to
them and there are creatures that do
this exact thing the most famous of
these is obviously the electric eel
which is able to release powerful
electric shocks upwards of 650 volts
five times more powerful than a standard
US wall socket it then uses those shocks
to stun their prey so they can eat them
believe it or not this actually lines up
really well with what we see and how to
train your dragon rather than launching
targeted lightning beams from his mouth
toothless is instead able to create
smaller electric Sparks around its body
in the Hidden World toothless seems to
create electric potentials all across
his own body resulting in electricity
crackling Across the Skin before
lightning from a storm cloud ultimately
hits him in short How to Train Your
Dragon gives us the most most realistic
portrayal of what a dragon's lightning
powers would have to look like in real
life moving on to the coolest of the
attacks that we see in these movies ice
breath see what I did there I said cool
and you thought that I meant cool as an
awesome but I meant literally cool like
from a temperature basis
thermodynamically cool just wanted you
all to appreciate the layered Nuance
that goes into these streamy
award-winning scripts anyway and How to
Train Your Dragon 2 we meet the bewilder
beasts giant dragons that breathe out
super cooled liquid that's able to
freeze on contact now know what you're
saying a reptile that breathes ice
sounds impossible and you're not wrong
as cold-blooded animals reptiles and Ice
just don't mix all that well you ever
seen a lizard just out in the wild
hanging out in a rock bacon in the sun
it's doing that to get heat from The
Rock in the sun to regulate its body
temperature somewhere between 12 and a
half to 35 degrees Celsius or 54 and a
half 95 degrees Fahrenheit depending on
what animal you're talking about much
higher than the temperature of ice but
if we stop and take a look at how the
bewilder beasts act in the movie we can
actually find a scientifically feasible
explanation for this breath weapon in
fact it would actually function very
similar lead to fire breath except in
Reverse you see explosions and fire well
those are exothermic reactions they're
chemical reactions that release a ton of
heat to create ice breath that freezes
on contacts our dragons would need to
create the exact opposite reaction than
that an endothermic reaction where the
reactants absorb heat energy from their
surroundings thereby making things
colder and we actually have the perfect
example of this in our day-to-day lives
using instant ice packs if you've ever
gotten into an injury these things are
clutch and the beauty of them is that
they're just super simple the liquid
inside the cold pack is just water easy
but inside the water is another tube
that contains ammonium nitrate a common
ingredient of fertilizer when you bend
the ice pack and cause the inner tube to
break that ammonium nitrate salt
dissolves into the water around it to
create an endothermic chemical reaction
that absorbs heat this reaction then
causes the water to cool down and the
pack becomes ice now just look at the
bewilder beast as he breathes he's
breathing out a liquid that freezes into
ice on contact just like with the fire
breath the dragon could store water in
one side of its body body and the
ammonium nitrate in another that would
then allow the dragon to keep a stable
internal body temperature despite being
a cold-blooded creature the chemical
reaction that creates the ice isn't
happening until after it breathes out
those two reactants a cool attack that
would be powered by even cooler science
and Heck if the animal needed more
protection maybe it's insulated with
layers of blubber like some ancient
reptilian dinosaurs had that would
explain why the bewilder beasts are just
so naturally big but now let's switch
gears into something completely
different something that really starts
to get us out of the realm of fantasy in
the original How to Train Your Dragon
the Thunder Drum dragon uses a
sound-based breath weapon when startled
the thunder drum produces a concussive
sound that can kill a man at close range
surprise we already have animals in the
real world that you sound like a gun
case in point the pistol shrimp this
little guy is no joke and its power
comes from this massive claw when it
wants to intimidate an opponent's attack
prey or even burrow into a rock it's
able to snap the claw shut quickly
enough to shoot an air bubble at
whatever it's aiming at at long ranges
that makes a loud scary sound but at
short range it can stun or flat out kill
any other small shrimp or fish again
exactly like what we hear about with the
thunder drum produces a concussive sound
that can kill a man at close range and
when you look at the science here it's
easy to see how they're so lethal the
snap of the claw produces a sound that
can reach 218 decibels in volume
underwater just how loud is that well a
whisper it's roughly 30 decibels a
normal conversation is about 60 decibels
at a rock concert hits at around 120
decibels but decibels rise exponentially
that means that a 10 decibel increase
makes the sound 10 times louder the 218
decibel pistol shrimp is roughly 10
billion times louder than the 120
decibel concert yep you're that right
billion with a B now the numbers there
aren't going to exactly line up one to
one with what you'd probably expect
because Sound Works differently
underwater it's muffled by the different
pressures but the sound is powerful
enough that American submarines used to
use reefs full of pistol shrimp to hide
from Japanese sonar and as you can see
here in this video the pops made by the
pistol shrimp are incredibly loud
compared to their size audible even
through aquarium glass
if a dragon were able to reproduce this
sort of attack above the water Maybe by
snapping its jaw shut quickly it would
be devastating and as an added bonus we
see in How to Train Your Dragon that the
dragons rely on sound as one of their
primary senses while hunting make lots
of it throw off on Dragon's Aim so not
only would the sound potentially be
deadly but it's also going to be
devastating for any opponent's
navigational abilities which brings us
now to one of the easiest attacks to
explain using science acid breath and
How to Train Your Dragon 3 the
villainous grimmel has several tamed
death gripper dragons that spew acid
that's able to corrode for almost
anything it touches now while the
strength of the death gripper acid is
definitely cranked up to 11 for the
movies this sort of offensive ability is
pretty darn common across the animal
kingdom several insects like termites
ants and scorpions are able to spray or
sting with acid while many species of
Cobra are just able to accurately spew
their acidic Venom several feet away
even some birds like the fulmar patrol
and turkey vulture can vomit up stomach
acid and use it as a projectile weapon
that is pretty darn gross it is also
pretty darn similar to what we see the
death grippers do in the movies so nope
really need to explain it much further
than that so as it turns out these sorts
of breath weapons are shockingly
plausible in real life there are real
world animals out there right now using
these very attacks like the pistol
shrimp in the spitting cobra and if
they're not using the exact attack then
they're using mechanisms that are pretty
darn close to what we see happening in
fantasy media like with the Bombardier
beetle and the electric eel but you know
what they say truth can be Stranger Than
Fiction and in the case of dragons all
of us are sleeping on the terror that is
the real life dragon the Komodo dragon
well we're busy creating fantasy worlds
like Burke these guys are just hanging
out in Indonesia and while we're
concocting explanations for fire breath
and freeze breath and lightning Rays
these lumbering monitor lizards are just
decimating the competition not with
breath attacks but with the bite attacks
the Komodo dragon has a very powerful
Venom that's generated in several ducts
between their teeth injecting that Venom
into anything it wants to eat or just
eat later the Venom contains over 50
different toxic proteins a deadly mix
that rapidly decreases the blood
pressure of its victim Expediting blood
loss and sending their bodies into shock
rendering the prey to week to fight back
the Komodo dragon then just rolls over
and eats him at their Leisure and the
craziest part of it all it is so
effective that the bite doesn't even
need to be that strong Studies have
shown that the Komodo Dragon's bite is
weaker than that of the common house cat
as long as it pierces the skin that's
all it needs in the end for as
Fantastical as dragons may seem in pop
culture the science is right there in
the nature around us sure the pistol
shrimp might not be sitting atop his
horde of gold and he might not be able
to ride a Komodo dragon as majestically
through the air as hiccup on top of
Toothless but animal world is crazy and
we're understanding more about the
wonders of how it works every single day
in this world full of technology and
screens and CGI we often Overlook that
our world is already a really cool place
filled with Incredible creatures
sometimes it takes a fictional series to
help us appreciate the real life wonders
around us but hey that doesn't mean that
we should be depriving ourselves of the
fantasy and you can get more Dragon
goodness right now thanks to the sponsor
of today's episode call of dragons this
new MMO fantasy Conquest game for iOS
Android and PC is from the creators of
Rise of Kingdoms and it plays like a
Forex strata energy game mashed together
with the best elements of MMORPGs
allowing you to explore a new fantasy
world all while recruiting Elven maidens
Mighty Orcs And Powerful Mages to your
cause but the real selling point here
dragons I mean come on it's in the name
call of dragons the game features a ton
of giant Behemoth monsters that you can
tame and unleash onto the battlefield
including giant bears Thunder rocks and
of course the fire-breathing dragon let
me tell you there is nothing more
satisfying than getting a dragon out
onto the field and changing the tide of
battle well maybe one day when I'm able
to get my hands on that lightning
railgun yeah that that'd be pretty darn
cool but until then there's call of
dragons between running these channels
and spending time with the family let me
tell you I don't have a ton of time to
play games anymore especially the really
in-depth RPGs that I grew up loving but
having a game like Call of dragons on my
phone where I can play in between
meetings and recordings it's awesome I
highly recommend that you check it out
by going to their official website by
scanning the QR code that you see on
screen right now or clicking the link in
the description below and using the
promo code TFT play COD for a special
bonus that's TFT p-l-a-y c-o-d thank you
again to call the dragons for sponsoring
today's episode and I'll see you all
next week with a brand new installment
until then as always my friends remember
it's all just a theory a film Theory and
cut